breaking news in a woman who killed
seven-year-old emily jones
in a park in bolton in march has been
sentenced
to life in prison gerard tubbs outside
the court
in manchester and she's going to be held
in a a secure hospital gerard
yes this is a truly appalling case
really sad story uh emily you may
remember
mothering sunday this year just before
full lockdown had gone with her father
mark to queen's park in bolton
um and emily's mum sarah was
going for a jog there they'd gone along
to see her and emily had seen her mum
and had asked
her dad if she could scoot her off down
to meet her he said yes she went off
calling to her mother
but unknown to any of them a 30 year old
albanian eltiana
scana who was a paranoid schizophrenic
who should have been taking
uh medicine for that and hadn't been
was sitting on a bench and emily scooted
past her
scanner jumped up she had bought a craft
knife in a shop
and she um killed she slit her throat
and killed emily
and she was arrested
and she obviously admitted it she has
been in custody needless to say
since we heard from her father in court
in an impact statement read out
describing emily uh as the beat of her
parents
hearts the skip in their step and the
judge
sentenced her as you say to be detained
under
uh section 45a of the mental health act
she has been
imprisoned for life with a minimum of
eight years
uh but she will initially be treated at
rampton high security hospital
if she's deemed well enough to leave
there she will go on
to serve the rest of her sentence in
hospital the judge said
she had to be punished because she had
made the decision
to buy the knife she had made the
decision to kill someone there was
an element of culpability in her
actions most of her family many of her
family members were in court including
her father
but they didn't say anything they left
with the judge's words ringing in their
ears at the end of the sentencing
hearing
saying that they had conducted
themselves with dignity